my scent on the schedule is more so this
is it cause back to 12
hey man don't you think what I promised
[Music]
okay
oh [__] you close and leave you
[__] out the cold out there
dying of it [__] where's uncle Joey
never [__] the podcast returns
tomorrow at 1 o'clock but today we'll
just take it easy we want you
[__] to experience life to say
bonjour
he can't be listening to podcasts all
your [__] lights you got to do
something you'll start your own podcast
and listen to what the world has to say
about you [__] you don't say but it's a
good old day I was driving by I saw Lee
was here and I thought what a better
time to do a [__] ball game
he's I'm saying because sometimes with
all the Christmas and the humbug we
forget what the [__] the purpose is and
that's to see the devil on a daily basis
you understand me because not life gets
difficult you just want to say it you'll
need to hang out with him you'll need to
breathe this [__]
[Music]
you want to [__] around do you want to
[__] then you know hang out with your
little micro doses down at Starbucks
it's uncle Joey interrupting your
[__] table de dah type of day to let
you know you're alive [__]
take that [__] to the hoop Jack if
Harvey did it so can you
it's [__] December 26 a beautiful day
to be alive I did a few things I went to
class I [__] went to the dentist this
morning 8:00 a.m. they were drilling
into my [__] head thank God I had
like ten thousand milligrams of edibles
of meat from the weekend you know when
Santa shows up he shows up big
[__] ly got bronchitis I told
them the recipe to take care of
bronchitis it's right here this is the
answer all your dilemmas CTE you and you
get hit in the head let's say you're a
football this is you right and also some
flying black guy comes BAM and your head
flies off you still got the mushroom
Jack this will bring you back you'll
start getting memories and flashbacks
maybe of things that never even happened
but who gives a [__] at least should
kick in this [__] but wait a second if
you're under 18 hang up now I'll need
you [__] in my life
send them emails Joey where's the
shrooms you get dick [__] go suck
on a lollipop and get back to me
go get high on sugar you little [__]
look at this coconut clean off
oh it's snuggly this Rudolph the Red
Nosed Reindeer we're going deep
[__] I'm lucky you showed up
get them saying we're ready for a little
gap that thing is [__] that thing is
clean Bobby that thing is clean Bobby
[Music]
you know saying just couple Barnet's in
the afternoon to break up the [__]
soiree that is called life uncle Joey
you know podcast today we're back
tomorrow one o'clock
rocking your [__] world that specific
[__] so if your name's coast it's 4
o'clock do the math or take your iPhone
out and do the [__] where you live in
[__] call [__] Audrey whatever our
name is on the [__] phone what's the
name
Siri my low-balled Siri call Siri and
say Siri how long I don't even know what
the [__] question was doesn't matter
doesn't matter we're here all together
having a [__] tremendous evil time oh
[__] look what I found
please petrified star and what do you
think it wasn't a yarmulke Jack that's a
[__] sign
we're going deep one more body what do
you think I'm not gonna bother to show
up like some [__] apple fruit game I'm
bothering you cuz I'm coming [__]
heavy
[Music]
one of my favorite all-time out when I
heard this album I knew I was gonna do
blow I knew it was all over arrow was it
of everything once I heard this out
[Music]
listen you gotta back that [__]
you understand me five beautiful South
African Jew diamond Twitter some South
Africans [__] bleeding from the head
have some Jews taken an envelope right
there that's what happens a black dude
bleeds a Jew gets an envelope you follow
me you get the equation the [__] you
think you're dealing with took me is to
figure that one out anyway
let's do another fun what about [__]
science teacher
[Music]
what the only one who can navigate tell
that cloud is Sully
maybe you know I'm saying maybe even
suddenly would be old [__] what the [__]
is this
don't forget January 6 working our
double Joey at the ice out the 18th in
Austin Texas then the following week the
last week of the month comin charlotte
[__] i still haven't done stand-up to
the first I'm sticking to my guns I'm
getting by saying you put me in a cage
and don't feed me for [__] three
weeks think what type of handle more I
would be I'd be a [__] X ray
that would be good but I'd be [__]
pissed at somebody else and I'm getting
pissed again heavy like we don't do
stand-up for 6 days it's like I've seen
your shrink is I'm saying so you get all
these evil thoughts I want to pack them
in so by the time I get to Austin I just
come out with a [__] ball of fire
[__] anyway Joey what's would be
a brief let's keep doing some bong at
this [__]
[Music]
that's a [__] would that's what comes
out of your ass hole at night after you
[__] suck ten dicks so big
it's just us hanging out with family and
say we're family [__] I'm with
you you're with me and they want to be
with our stories remember that all right
let me get a little [__] hog wanted
me you gotta rehydrate when you're doing
your little THC thing
[Music]
oh [__]
like I said one of my favorite that runs
smack down hello Willie I don't know if
it's a stereo I don't [__] know all
right no it is a dirty
I think it's dream on get your wings and
[__] rocks can you imagine it a band
today could [__] do something right
that's not even close three [__] fast
balls on the road that don't happen no
more but anyway you know what does
happen bong hits that's what happens
[__] look at the jar debt this
used to be a baby applesauce Charlie
what we did was a little shout out the
[__] the people will make baby food
yawns oh [__]
wait bed cutie once your sucks that
fooling anyway let's do this [__]
bonk it
and I'll let you go on your [__]
married date but don't say I didn't
check in with you that's the most
important thing most important thing in
life keeping your friends giving your
family and check check in with it but
you gotta be an [__] for check in
with your McCall what's going on I
didn't expect you called no cuz people
don't do that [__] drove off it's like a
[__] punch to the kidney yeah what
the [__] is this [__]
same thing you want to check in here to
check in on a daily flow and walk what
up how you feelin it - dirt what's going
on that's your life lesson from uncle
Joey today
[Music]
[Applause]
we want from me I'm over here delivering
the goods on a daily understand me I'm a
[__] daily delivering the goods for
you can't stop this anyway I gotta take
two steps to the rear and get out of
here but I love you [__] don't
forget about me get your [__] goals
ready 2018 still here and you're still
on your grandma's couch you should be
shot and hung and thrown under the
[__] Jail oh hey who the [__] am I the
judge of the execution anyway get those
goals
do those playthrough push-ups throw
those opiates in the garbage and pick up
a joint [__] it's your best bet
go buy some creepy weed over there in
your neighborhood but besides that you
know I love you the weed hit me like a
ton of bricks I got [__] to do and
people to see all right have a good day
keep your eyes open cos it's the time of
the year Isis wants to [__] up your new
year you don't say so you see anything
suspicious a [__] sandal anything you
watch that [__] you understand me
I love you have a good day and we'll see
that you tomorrow the church or what's
happening now tour dates t-shirts
candles everything Joey Diaz dotnet go
there right now [__] you ain't
doing nothing you're watching this like
a [__] once I love you stay black